john boy had a phenomenal breakdown of
this on youtube back here on the rich
island show how are you doing john boy
i'm doing well thank you for having me i
i'm glad that uh
you want to chat about it because nobody
wants to talk about this why
why i don't i don't know i mean i i
usually have a lot of baseball reporters
or you know
quote-unquote verified people in the
baseball world share the breakdowns
comment on them and this one got like
nothing no one wants to touch it
is it because everybody's doing it is
that why maybe
yeah it's it's because the players
haven't actively come out and
said we don't like this until this
season
and and it's the first time and i think
you know you listen to the players
there's some players now and now a
manager on record saying it's cheating
and we don't like it and
that voice is going to grow louder and
hopefully people care but for right now
no one seems to care i i i'm i'm stunned
so um honestly you know and i'm i've
i've been around long enough to to
to be hard bitten or um
completely you know uh immune to
seeing stuff that just makes you shocked
i mean i
i was sitting on sportscenter set during
the steroid ever man
era you know uh and so now
now this kind of just surprises me
because it's affecting
the game it's affecting the forget about
pace of play you want to you want to
spice things up how about
how about getting this crap off of
people's hands that makes the spin rates
turn the baseballs into being unhittable
what is the stuff that you're that you
think is on the baseballs
john boy well there's a lot now like um
on the chris rose show uh beralt
and trevor williams said some guys are
using like ceramic cement
what uh i know bauer had talked about
uh you know firm grip and pine tar and
rosin
and i even heard like coke boiled in
coca-cola until it's
hard uh pelican grip is now
basically it is what it is uh one of
those concoctions that they sell now
it's called pelican grip
and it's it's it's just like glue
and the big difference is you know it's
not for grip it's for spin i think
that's the easiest way to
let people know this is different than
what we've really dealt with in the past
where
it's it you know a lot of times it is
for grip and batters always said
i don't care if he needs a better grip
i'd rather him throw it in the zone than
out of his own right
but what happened was it's really
interesting kind of fascinating story of
the development of this
because in the early 2000s uh the angels
kind of developed it or maybe
it was troy percival told the angels um
clubby how to make it and but they
didn't have the high
resolution spin rate cameras then so i
don't think they had the combination of
like oh
this leads to this because they didn't
have the tech and people weren't
counting spin rate
they just thought you know he's got a
jackrabbit fastball or a late life
but now that we're getting these
formulas and concoctions plus the
ability
to throw a pitch with it on your fingers
off your fingers and see the instant
difference
it's going crazy because every pitcher
is saying whoa it's an instant fix
you watch more baseball than anybody
that maybe i know of john boy and break
it down
i mean you're also one of the
world-class lip readers of all time it's
impressive how you can
read all the lips that you do so when
i'm watching a game
what what should i look for from a
pitcher to know something's up
what do i see after a foul ball so after
every foul ball watch where the
pitcher's hand goes
because that means he's getting a new
ball that hasn't been doctored yet
right so um you know usually it's the
inside of the glove they used to hide it
more
and go you know bring over the hat a lot
of people do that but
now because they kind of free range this
season to do it
uh you know and i think the broadcast
showed karen check on the indians last
night
going to the glove and it's really in
the the thumb of the glove you'll see
them go but
it's whenever they get a new ball in
play so after a home run or a foul ball
foul balls are the easiest
and you you'll be able to tell and i
like what schiltz said
uh when he said watch people who lick
their fingers because those guys aren't
putting
the stuff on the ball if they're licking
their fingers i like that note so
is it clear is that why you can't like
what what what does it look like have
you seen what it looks like
john boy whatever i think there's all
different kinds karen shacks was like
black
yesterday uh so i i don't know if
there's a consistent
color well i guess it's not consistent
that it works because karen shack was
getting his ass handed to him in the
ninth inning last night
john boy before he got the final out i
mean he was that thing was blown up
blown to [ __ ] shane bieber's win was
almost out the window so i guess it's
not guaranteed to always work
i imagine yeah just improve your
fastball but
you gotta have you gotta have some skill
already i think it's just like corking a
bat
you know you can you can swing one bat
and make great contact and it will go
this distance
and then you can in in batting practice
you can switch back have the same swing
and it will go a different distance
that's what this is you can throw one
fast
i'll have this spin rate and then you
can dip your fingers into your glove and
throw the next fastball and now you've
improved your fastball and
you didn't you didn't have to train in
between or do anything different it's
are you just changing the equipment
really well i guess john boy of john boy
media here on the rich eisen show i
guess we're we're we're now treading
into the waters why i think maybe
some some people don't want to talk
about it is because
you know just because somebody's going
to a glove doesn't mean that's what
they're doing yeah i mean we just
basically accused the closer of the
indians last night of putting this gunk
on his hands
um and is it always
you know a slam dunk case when you see
that happening that this is what
is in fact happening in major league
baseball john boy
well i don't i don't know probably not i
guess i shouldn't sit here and say that
it's slammed on case and yes he's using
it but my guess would be that there
it's something yeah i think i think
majority of pitchers
put stuff on the ball and i think um
i would say almost all are gonna either
like use the rosin and the sweat
uh or something to get more grip i think
it's the
scraping the two fingers uh in in this
new concoction
i would say it's still majority i would
say i think even bauer someone said it's
like six out of ten pitchers seven out
of ten
and then probably ten out of ten the
other what you can look for is if a guy
ever
rubs his forearm i mean that that's
sunscreen and rosin
mixture that they're getting there which
can just give you overall like a better
feel for the baseball
but it's that's been i mean technically
is
i don't know technically is illegal or
legal because everyone says well they're
just two things that you have on your
body you're not gonna be able to police
that no one
seems to care about that so i i don't
know if you can say yeah he went to his
glove or went to his hat
it's it's this new stuff that is
instant cheating or whatever but you can
guess they're doing something let's just
say this then
john boy here on the rich eisen show
let's just say what is going on with
baseballs
uh and those who are using it to pitch
and creating a spin rate that is not
usually something that they could do
just with their own talents than the
shift
then the concept that so many hitters
are being sent to the plate
without a sensibility of making contact
or a shame of striking out
is this why we're seeing so many
no-hitters in so many innings where
there are no balls put into play
is that what is are we seeing this right
here john boy
and then the biggest factor is that mlb
uh dead into the balls this season and
they they made it public they announced
that they were going to do it
because the the ball was juiced in 2019
we saw so many home runs
uh the most amount of home runs per game
ever i think in 2019 broke all sorts of
records
and they wanted to get away from that
because they think the home run isn't
a lot of action and they thought that
taking the home run out would
bring more doubles and base hits and
batters would change their approach
but what they did they dead in the ball
so it's lighter
it spins more out of the pitcher's hands
and it uh is softer off the bat
so that plus giving cardi blanche all
the pitchers to use this substance
um because they told them that they're
gonna you know take
balls out of games and send them to a
lab but they're not you won't get
punished we're just
doing research so now you have uh
a dead-end ball and pitchers
not scared to be doctoring the balls
with this new concoction
so yeah that's why we have so many no
hitters okay and so why
what do you think is going on with with
the baseball front office
then because i know i mean the people
that i know there the last thing they
want is cheating
and the last thing they want is anybody
having a conversation like this i mean
they'd much rather us talk about how
great otani is and
tatis and you know uh okunyu i could go
down the list and they are worthy of
of having a conversation but it's why
would they
allow like why would they let this go
and then and no wonder shield goes crazy
when joe west is like yeah change your
hat
you know what i mean like now now that
makes complete sense that he's like
flipping out when when when they go to
his picture and say change your hat
what what do you think is happening
what's happening mlb
culture forever has been keep everything
within the walls of baseball and
if it leaks then we'll let it leak for
three years and then if people get
really upset maybe we'll do something
about or maybe we'll get another five
years and then we'll do something about
it but
i don't know and then the baseball thing
it's just um
ineptitude there's a scientist out there
dr meredith wills who does a lot of
research on this and we had on our show
and you know they got juiced in 2017 and
we saw a home run surge they went back
to somewhat normal in 18
in 2019 they were incredibly juiced if
you go back to 2014 it was a dead ball
it was like the least amount of home
runs per game since 1981.
so in the last you know decade we've had
so many
different products of baseballs which is
the main equipment of the sport and golf
is very tight with their
with their ball with their the what's
allowed and what's not and
i i don't think it's on purpose i'd i
you know i don't think that baseball
juice the balls like the i think the
story was they changed manufacturers and
they got wound tighter
i and then they did admit to deducing
them and trying to deaden them and
and the desired result was more action
and fled to
a lot less action so it
i that's that's also a story like i know
that that story came out on the athletic
and then
uh the athletic wrote about this this uh
new sticky stuff
right and i think everyone thought
people were gonna care but nobody
seems to care about these two things
that are drastically affecting
the product then last then last thing
for you what about the players again
your your
media group and the shows that you put
on uh
have tons of players and players watch
your stuff and players respect your
stuff i mean i saw
chris rose at the draft you know uh with
nfl network he loves doing
the show that he's doing for you and
john boy media and with you guys
and the players that come on you even
said you had a couple
talk about this did do they like it are
they
i mean like were they like what are the
hitters thinking i mean i can imagine
certain hitting coaches must be looking
across
at the pitchers in their locker room and
just say do you see what's going on with
the hitters on this team i mean
you know you see what's going on with my
ass is on the line you know what i mean
like i i'm wondering what what are what
are the players
thinking about all of this yeah i think
it's always been hard because every
every hitter shares a locker with a
pitcher who's probably doing something i
i think the vast majority and the main
names
in the cardinals rotation don't use
this new concoction and are proud that
they don't
and they don't like being lumped in when
people say everybody does it
and they i think that you know schiltz
said he talked to his guys before going
public so i'm guessing they gave him the
okay it was probably more than an okay
was probably like please
say something we've had players um
reach out that no trevor or know me um
asking to you know hey can you guys talk
about this uh can you get
because some hitters are getting sick of
it and and now we had um
real muto go on the record in the
athletic article a catcher
up anyone he touches every ball thrown
basically
he would know and i mean he he catches
them from his
pitching staff so it's a very
interesting dynamic but he went on
record saying i wanted to stop
so it's starting to get uh louder from
the players
but i i think for a while it was you
know i share a locker room with a guy
that's also doing this
so i don't want to piss him off i mean
schiltz what he had to say couldn't have
been more behind the scenes right he
couldn't have lifted the kimono anymore
with his post game right yeah
no i i think you know i think the
athletic article with the real muto and
the duval quotes came out
uh rosenthal and uh guerrelli wrote that
one i think it came out
like a week before so this is like a
slow build and
finally that's why i said all right i'll
make a video on and try to explain this
and
and get it you know dumb it down as best
as possible
uh but we'll see still seems like no one
cares
well at least we're talking about it
before i let you go how concerned about
the yankees are you
pretty concerned pretty concerned they
can't hit
i mean their bottom five in offense
and the other teams in the bottom five
are the pirates
the orioles and the royals i believe no
not the royals it's
it's like the diamond packs or another
team that's not trying james they're
actually trying
they are trying and that's all that you
know you know uh
they they they used to have half a dozen
um
lemay hughes john boy that could do
everything and put the ball in play and
you know the years when they won all
those world series they weren't leading
you know they didn't have any leaders
singular leaders pretty much in home
runs
um and that's how they beat you they
they
they got the lead by putting the ball in
play putting the pressure on the
opposition then sending rivera out there
when it came time to
shorten the game you know and it's just
i i don't recognize it
i just don't recognize it you know tory
came over and he implemented the stolen
base and hitting runs and using speed
and
this is this team is the slowest team in
all of baseball and and
they get thrown down the base paths
twice a game john boy thanks for the
call appreciate it everyone
should check out uh your your breakdown
on the subject matter that we just broke
down over the last 15 minutes appreciate
the call man
thank you for having me you got it
that's john boy of john boy media check
out everything that he puts out there
it's real it's real it's real real real
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here